Довго запрягають - швидко їдуть?
Ще минулого тижня уряд ФРН категорично відкидав постачання важких озброєнь Україні.
А два дні тому стало відомо про згоду німецького уряду на поставку Україні зенітних самохідних установок "Гепард".
Більше того, депутати Бундестагу від правлячих партій та опозиційного блоку ХДС/ХСС
закликали уряд ФРН розширити і пришвидшити надання Україні важкого озброєння.
Про це йдеться в ухваленій 28 квітня резолюції під назвою "Захист миру та свободи в Європі - всебічна підтримка України".
Крім всеосяжної економічної ізоляції Росії, посилення та прискорення поставок "ефективних, у тому числі важких озброєнь"
є "найважливішим і найефективнішим засобом зупинення російського просування", сказано в документі.
Альтернативи наразі немає. Переговори з Володимиром Путіним не просуваються, радше навпаки.
Поки їхні делегації нібито борються за мир, Росія навіть не дає можливості евакуювати людей.
І тому ми мусимо негайно дати військову відповідь.
Так, це не є гарно, ніхто з нас цього не хотів.
Але я переконана, що з огляду на агресію Росії і жагу територіального панування РФ це єдина відповідь.
Фрідріх Мерц, лідер опозиційної фракції ХДС, яка ініціювала резолюцію,
різко розкритикував канцлера ФРН Олафа Шольца, заявивши, що той протягом багатьох тижнів
вагався та ухилявся від постачання озброєнь Україні.
Канцлер ФРН упродовж тижнів затягував дискусію щодо постачання зброї Україні,
залишав питання відкритими і давав розмиті відповіді.
Аргумент канцлера, що наша німецька зброя, імовірно, розв'яже третю світову війну,
є безвідповідальним і з огляду на нашу історію також неправильним і помилковим.
Адже це залишає місце для припущення, що, з точки зору канцлера, всі інші країни,
які більше роблять для України, ніж ми, а таких багато,
що вони підвищують небезпеку війни в Європі.
Пані та панове, на мою думку, це гротескне перекручування причин та відповідальності за цю війну.
Чому саме німецька зброя має мати цю дію, а всі інші - ні?
У відповідь співголова партії Шольца СДПН Ларс Клінґбайль
звинуватив Мерца у намаганнях заробити своїй партії бонуси на цьому питанні.
Керівництво СДПН відкинуло звинувачення в нерішучості і продовжує повторювати,
що постачання озброєнь в Україну не має нашкодити обороноздатності самої Німеччини
та виконанню зобов'язань перед партнерами по НАТО.
У нас є принципи. Ми сказали, що узгоджуємо свої дії з міжнародними партнерами.
Ми казали, що ми не шкодимо нашій власній обороноздатності.
І ми казали, що ми самі не стаємо стороною у війні.
Це правильно і важливо, що ми з парламенту даємо чіткий сигнал Володимиру Путіну,
чіткий сигнал людям в Україні, що ми як німецький Бундестаг стоїмо на правильній стороні історії.
Представники Зелених наголосили, що Німеччина, попри своє бажання не ставати стороною конфлікту,
не може залишати Україну беззахисною перед російською агресією.
Раніше віцеканцлер Габек так сформулював позицію німецьких Зелених.
Ми, безумовно, мали підтримати Україну у військовому відношенні набагато раніше,
і я говорю не про дні або тижні, а про роки, і це, звичайно, помилка, яка була допущена в минулому.
Це стосується, безумовно, і недавнього минулого.
Але той факт, що ми не були досить швидкими, не означає, що ми не маємо бути швидкими зараз.
Ми вже багато робимо. Ми дбаємо про важке озброєння, яке надходить в Україну.
З тим бюджетом, який ми виділили, Україна має можливість купувати більше зброї, купувати важкі озброєння.
Західні військові експерти переконані що надання такої техніки Україні може змінити перебіг бойових дій в Україні.
Це дуже важливе рішення. Щодо самої зброї, "Гепардів", то це досить стара конструкція, але вона була модернізована.
У німецькій армії "Гепарди" зняли з озброєння близько 10 років тому. Але у багатьох арміях їх досі використовують.
Вони дуже потужні, із малою дальністю стрільби.
Але якщо ви пілот і опинитеся поблизу, то у вас не так багато шансів.
Але є не лише прямий ефект від використання "Гепардів".
Сам факт володіння ними тримає військову авіацію на відстані.
Німецька армія припинила їх експлуатувати майже десятиліття тому не через те, що вони застарілі,
а тому що Бундесвер зменшив військову активність і для них не було більше сфер застосування.
Тепер Бундесвер шкодує про це, оскільки на ППО короткої дальності великий попит нині скрізь, і особливо в Україні.
Українці можуть скористатися ними. Безперечно.
Але це залежатиме від того, скільки часу займе навчання українців керувати "гепардами".
Вони не такі вже й складні за сучасними мірками,
але вимагають багато тренувань із електронними радарами та сенсорами.
На думку офіцера британської розвідки Френка Ледвіджа, ухваливши рішення про постачання зброї Україні,
Захід не може більше вдавати, що він залишається осторонь конфлікту.
Ми бачимо, що українцям постійно надсилається стандартне обладнання НАТО.
Я думаю, що це змінює ситуацію. Тому що це більше залучає НАТО до конфлікту.
Окрім зенітних самохідних установок "Гепард", німецька компанія Rheinmetall подала запит до уряду ФРН
на передачу Україні 88 вживаних танків Leopard та сотні БМП Marder,
а група Krauss-Maffei Wegmann подала запит щодо сотні САУ "Panzerhaubitze 2000".